foreign
of course I didn't misrepresent anything
why would I
Metro Police in the hot seat in a court
battle over the phone of murdered review
journal reporter Jeff gearman now this
is all part of a battle over what and
when police can access gearman's phone
which contains confidential information
including his sources thanks for joining
us here at six I'm Denise Valdez and I'm
Brian Loftus 8 news now investigative
reporter and legal expert Kyle Payne was
at that hearing where attorneys were
pointing a lot of fingers at each other
here's Kyle Brian Metro lawyers admitted
a detective did a preliminary search of
the phone despite that admission the
court decided not to sanction Metro now
homicide detectives want to do a more
thorough search and the RJ is fighting
to protect those sources
that phone and for computers and a hard
drive belonging to the murder Las Vegas
Review journal's investigative reporter
Jeff gearman who was killed in September
a screeching halt to the murder trial of
former Clark County public administrator
Robert Tellis who was indicted in
October for stabbing Airman outside the
reporter's home particularly
inappropriate to have Metro doing the
search but it was Metro who was on the
hot seat today because the review
journal accused police of searching
Urban's phone at the scene of the crime
which they say is a violation of
well-established state and federal law
that federal statute
it was violated at the moment 56 devices
were seized by Metro lawyers for the
newspaper asking the court to appoint an
independent third party to review the
phone so gearman's confidential
information and sources can be kept from
going public he's an investigative
reporter
now exactly really good stuff and and
the murder trial will be about that
before the murder trial though this
issue with the phone and computers need
to be dealt with and the review
journal's lawyers say Metro isn't
playing Fair there's a high probability
news gathering information do you agree
with that uh yes I do agree with that
the newspaper he won awards writing for
would like to keep his Secrets secret
remember that the public is watching are
they going to trust this process
attorneys for the review journal said
they may appeal the ruling